у 1984 році не зміг би вигадати таку
Росію все те що відбувається
чим рішучіша країна виступають проти
путінської Росії тим більшу загрозу вони
мають
та розбрату в елітах близьких до Путіна
та армії
це буде довга війна на виснаження
сплановане святкування Дня Перемоги в
Росії на Красній площі мало на меті
показати всю військову міцерер чи дійсно
росіяни втомилися від бойових дій гостем
проєкту Deutsche Welle конфлікт Джон
стала Ніна Хрущова професорка
міжнародних відносин університету нова
школа у нью-йорку та правнучка
наступника Сталіна Микити Хрущова вона
провела місяці війни в Москві оскільки
Росія готується протистояти українському
контрнасту наскільки хиткою є позиція
Путіна
Ніна Хрущова Ласкаво просимо вас у
конфлікт Джон Дякую що запросили торік
як гості цієї програми ви сказали що
викриття недоліків російської армії
завдало великої шкоди Престижу влади
наскільки нині погіршилася ситуація для
Росії і самого Путіна особливо в День
Перемоги
Я думаю для Путіна питання Престижу
влади вже не так актуально подальша
стратегія яку обрала Росія і сам Путін
полягає в тому що вони не звертають
уваги на такі речі постійно кажуть що
спеціальна військова операція буде
завершена вона досягне поставлених цілей
і що не важливо оскільки часу це займає
і по суті схоже неважливо якою ціною
тому вони таки влаштували парад на день
перемоги це було дещо понуро Не так
грандіозно все тривало близько 15 хвилин
з яких Путін говорив близько десяти Але
по суті у них зараз дуже банальний
підхід ми Вою Росія воює А ви або
приймаєте Це або ні але фактично Росія
буде продовжувати війну і тих хто не
погоджується з таким підходом буде
ліквідовано
але велися розмови що численні поради до
Дня Перемоги були скорочені або
скасовані з міркувань безпеки Красна
площа була закрита для відвідувачів з
кінця квітня чи є це ознакою слабкості
Путіна і навіщо на вашу думку це
росіянам
вікна не тільки це є ознакою слабкості
зокрема брутальне обмеження свобод
Свобода мати права Свобода вираження
поглядів свободи слова і так далі були
майже повністю обмежені чи заборонені це
і є слабкість тому що слабкі держави
Мають дуже слабкі Свободи а саме це
зараз відбувається з Росією Отже Так це
ознака слабкості з точки зору заходу але
з російської точки зору це ознака сили
весь світ проти нас це гібридна війна
НАТО все ближче і до наших кордонів
почати спеціальну операцію було
правильним рішенням і так казав Кремль
тому якби не виглядала Росія Путін чи
крем із точки зору заходу вони будуть
проштовхувати свою риторику в Росії
торік у Росії опанувало почуття вічею та
недовіри протягом багатьох місяців а
зараз розпач із невіра фактично
перетворилися на повну відданість долі
багато хто розлючений як на Кремлі так і
на тих хто з точки зору росіян штовхає
Росію на ці дії
очікується Що більш активна фаза
боротьби і Росія і Україна готується до
наступного етапу війни оскільки
наближається український Контрнаступ Як
ви зазначили у Путіна не так багато
перемог тим часом Контрнаступ України
буде підтримуватися тисячами одиниць
нової західної бронетехніки і щойно
навченими військовими наскільки Високі
ставки зараз для Путіна особисто
ставки високі він почав війну думаючи що
це буде швидко і чітко і легко але так
не сталося ставки високі тому що зараз
його єдиний спосіб залишитися при владі
це продовжувати казати Я єдиний хто може
захистити вас від Західної агресії
тож для нього війна - це його політичний
Актив вона йому потрібна Якщо він не
переможе Тоді йому справді потрібне
продовження війни
навіть попри втрати ймовірно будуть ті
певні здобутки українська сторона та
західні радники теж наголошували що
Україні буде важко повернути всю
територію
певною мірою для Путіна чим довше триває
війна поки він не може перемогти тим
краще для його політичної установища
допоки все не стане настільки погано що
еліти з його оточення і народ Росії не
скажуть що варто переглянути стратегію
влади але я не думаю що це станиця
швидко
також надходили повідомлення про удари
поконтрольованих Росією територіях а
саме по прикордонних з Україною районах
нафтобаза в Криму два потяги зійшли з
рейок для військового керівництва Росії
це не виглядає добре нещодавно керівник
пвк Вагнер Євген пригожин закликав
збільшити кількість боєприпасів для
своїх бойовиків у бахмуті у якийсь
момент він навіть погрожував вивести їх
чи дійсно у військового керівництва
Росії великі проблеми
і так і ні вони мають проблеми Бо вони
не виграють але ці атаки які ви
зазначили для пропаганди фактично
підтверджують що вони були завдані
українською стороною Тому це ще раз
посилює аргумент Путіна що Подивіться
вони б'ють нас всюди цією новітньою
західною зброєю Тож як можна казати щоб
ми відступили та змінили свою поведінку
у російських військових не все добре але
пригожин веде свою гру Він вирішив
присоромити всіх і тому що він такий
потрібний він розраховував змінити все
на свою користь Рамзан Кадиров
чеченський бойовик та чеченський
президент такий самий негідник який
пригожин спочатку сказав ми візьмемо
владу в свої руки але потім він виступив
проти пригожина мовляв для початку Йому
треба було довести свою роботу до кінця
пригожин заявив що виводить свої
підрозділи із бахмута 10 травня але не
зробив цього діяльні ознаки Японії та
розбрату велітах близьких до Путіна та
армії втім це не означає що Росія
програє настільки що її програш у війні
є доконаним фактом це лише ті внутрішні
конфлікти які насправді можуть дозволити
війні тривати довше
повернімося до російського суспільства
чи є шанс Що росіяни зміняться тому що в
Росії деякі блогери які підтримують
війну вже попереджають що російська
лінія фронту може зазнати поразки перед
обличчям українського контрнаступу
виглядає так що в суспільстві зростає
тривога щодо можливостей армії все це на
тлі оцінок США за якими лише під
бахмутом загинуло близько 20 тисяч
росіян які зараз настрої в Росії чи
змінюються Вони
Ні не змінюється скоріше це видавання
бажаного за дійсне тому що військові
блогери так само комунікували приблизно
6 місяців тому вони казали Нам потрібно
тиснути нам потрібно зробити більше
потім ці наративи вщухли але зараз знову
піднімаються медіапросторі чи справді
сусідні держави можуть почуватися в
безпеці тому що згідно з нещодавно
злитими документами США група пвк Вагнер
була причетна до нібито очолюваних
кремлем спроб розпалити громадянські
заворушення в Молдові з метою
дестабілізувати про західний уряд
наскільки стурбованими повинні бути такі
країни як Молдова і скільки ще шкоди
здатний завдати Путін
такі країни як Молдова повинні
хвилюватися тому що в Молдові зараз
румунська мова є офіційною
чим рішучіша країна виступають проти
путінської Росії тим більшу загрозу вони
мають
бо російська влада не збирається
послаблювати своїх зусиль поки не
переконається що руський мір у безпеці
[музика]
тому чим рішучішими є антиросійські
настрої тим більше Путін так чи інакше
хотітиме вплинути на них
повернімося до внутрішньої ситуації в
Росії де ви провели місяців війни у
заголовках ми бачимо що такі
опозиціонери як Навальний як карамурза
сидять у в'язниці і все ж ви раніше
говорили про мовчазну більшість яка
чинить опіру Росії які докази цього ви
помітили
Динамо
Я дивлюся на цифри і намагаюся читати
Опитування
45% населення Росії кажуть що вони
підтримують війну або вони не проти
війни
25% цих людей насправді активно це
підтримують
інші 55% можуть підтримувати а можуть і
не підтримувати
не забуваємо що коли в Росії в
опитуванні ставлять таке запитання то
відповідь ні я не підтримую військового
спецоперацію може призвести до арешту
адміністративного покарання або ще
чогось Але як я вже зазначала я залишила
Росію у січні тоді настрої ще не були
мілітаристські війна що була чимось
далеким Я маю на увазі що ще тривало
життя зараз білборди з певним посилом
злість що ми не виграємо але і не
програємо наше життя вже ніколи не буде
таким як раніше Тож ми повинні
згуртуватися навколо прапора Влада
підтримує цю агресію бо її меседж такий
якщо ви не з нами То наш Україну
переможуть ви хочете цього багато росіян
відповідають не хоче йому бо ми не
знаємо що таке буде переможеною країною
медсестражно Можливо ми маємо принаймні
вдати що підтримуємо війну
Я хотіла б попросити вас оцінити ці
неративи про так зване повторне
пробудження тоталітарних інстинктів у
російському суспільстві коли люди пишуть
доноси один на одного як у сталінську
еру опозиція як ми вже згадували немає
голосу ув'язнена або у вигнанні яке
російське суспільство на вашу думку
формується із цієї війни
Я вважаю що це не просто пробудження
тоталітаризму бо за формулами
попереднього тоталітаризму навіть за
допомогою радикальних заходів ми
рухаємося вперед до чогось що може
зробити краще те Куди зараз рухається
Росія це 13 століття це повернення до
імперської влади навіть Джордж уреал у
1984 році не зміг би вигадати таку Росію
все те що відбувається все це вже наче
інша книга Джордж орелл 2022 з абсолютно
жахливими наслідками цієї війни
Як ви думаєте яким чином російське
суспільство врешті-решт пройде повз всі
ті жахи скоєні в Україні звинувачення у
воєнних злочинах зокрема примусова
депортація дітей зґвалтування тортури Ви
сподіваєтеся що зміни відбудуться і чи
відбудуться вони найближчим часом
не знаю я справді не знаю як суспільство
переживають воєнні злочини у нас є
приклад Німеччини але це рідкісний
приклад скоріше виняток ніж правило коли
я говорю про Гнів який наростає в
суспільстві це саме про те що оскільки
Вони збираються знищити нас Ми станемо
злими та більш націоналістичними на це і
робить став купутін як буде далі
залежить від того хто буде лідером
опозиції є якщо лідери опозиції
повернуться залежить від того яким чином
закінчиться війна хто прийде на заміну
Путіну бо врешті-решт це станеться адже
він якому вже 70 років
ціна може тривати протягом наступного
року якщо не довше у Путіна є ще рік чи
час йому на руку в цій війні
у війні на виснаження так час на його
боці Я думаю що чим довше це триватиме
тим не меншу кількість питань доведеться
відповідати Путіну допоки це не повна
поразка як пригожин постійного говорив я
думаю що ця війна - це новий Афганістан
це буде довга війна на виснаження я
припускаю що вона триватиме і в
наступному році а можливо і довше
частково або повномасштабно війна триває
вже понад рік і наразі Росія не виграє
так як її хочеться а Україна не втрачає
настільки щоб вибрати іншу тактику
ваш прадід прийшов до влади в Росії
Після смерті Сталіна а потім залишив
посаду шляхом мирної передачі влади хоча
тоді цього ніхто і передбачити не міг
чим на вашу думку може закінчитися
президентство Путіна
дуже багато невідомих невідомих я не маю
відповіді на це питання це залежить від
війни від того які саме ідеї переможуть
в Росії переможе Гнів суспільства і весь
цей хакі патріотизм чи переможе
прагнення бачити Росію глобальною
державою частиною світу що мене хочемо
пан держави яка повільно перетворюється
на північну Корею насправді хрущові
Горбачов були скоріше випадковістю в
російській історії ніж її реальністю
можливо після правління Путіна буде
якась реформа або Щось на кшталт
військового перевороту в Росії ніколи не
було військових переворотів Але все може
бути це може бути така революція коли
дійсно дуже войовничі сили прийдуть до
влади і скажуть вони ведуть на су цю
імперську Валерій 14 століття
недостатньо швидко всім Я не бачу це як
революцію з боку ліберальних сил
потенційно Я бачу це як революцію з боку
прихильників та військових сил але знову
ж таки тут багато невідомих все це
можливо але мабуть не скоро
Ніна Хрущова Дуже дякую що приєдналися
до нас на конфлікт-зон дякую